vision what scares you the most
hello what scares me the most
what scares me the most I think is not
getting to do what I'm meant to do here
in life so taking advantage of every
opportunity to create because that's how
I kind of learn about life and learn
about myself and just you know did you
always know you wanted to to create yes
in films not necessarily but from a very
very young age I used to look at a
paintbrush at the supermarket an artist
brush and just swoon over it I had no
idea what was going on except I had
these butterflies in me and then my
mother would come we can't afford it
walk me out I was like oh so but I had
the opportunity to do something creative
I knew I was you know I was hooked
what were the first things you created
paintings and I don't know exactly the
exact images yeah probably something
cute well what is he what was the
impetus to the transition into I was
doing a lot of photography after art
college I took one photography course
and art college and after four years but
there was something so immediate about
it I loved that it put me out with
people because as an artist who can be
complete loner and I do love that when I
create but you know it kind of can get
to so and it forced me to communicate
which as an artist you don't have to
know even the language English you don't
have to know anything except you know
your inner world and paint but so it
allowed me to share my ideas and how to
communicate and to be around people and
also how to find that sort of intuitive
nest that you have when you're an artist
how to do that in in in a film
environment and photography felt very
like a natural progression into film
because you've got you know the frame
you've got lighting I used to do all
that on my
so it's a natural progression do you do
everything on set now do you like do you
like look at things yeah I get involved
in everything from you know the hair
down to the shoes down to the color of
you know I but I surround myself with a
great team then kind of get on with and
then it's just sort of like kids in a
candy store what was it about the
tourney in particular that means you
want to adapt this and then turn this
into a film what I loved about is the
nature of how interpretive the material
is it's a dark story but you know you
can read it as a ghost story and then
you could read it as a psychological
story about a woman going mad and the
idea of that interpretation is what I
think makes it a really great framework
for a visual storytelling so yeah that
kind of drew me in for sure how much of
the script changed when you came aboard
the the film well the the script we kept
the structure okay from the Hayes
brothers but I wanted to make it a more
female centric and kind of really get
into the POV of Kate so we worked on
making that a more kind of the road that
we went down um the female centric part
of it really kind of getting into the
story through Kate did you always know
you wanted this to be sort of ambiguous
did you lean into that or was that
always sort of present I it was one of
the first things that I wanted to do
because the source material has lasted
over a hundred years you know people
talking about what does it mean and the
symbology in the in the book and and so
I kind of gravitated towards that kind
of ending because I think people can put
themselves into the film a bit more and
also you know the last act is more like
a fever dream you know you're kind of
really lost with like in get in Kate
psyche